he's indeed chris paddock on the hill 24
year old making his fourth start he is
2-0 and last time out against the
dodgers he pitched very well three
earned runs in six frames
he threw 14 curve balls he doesn't get
rattled two down and martay at first
base for
david peralta here's chris slow ground
ball paddock
will not even take a look he'll just
grab it underhand because that's it
runner was going from the contact does
it matter merrill
kelly makes his third start for the
diamondbacks of the season well we saw
him a little
bit last year this is the second season
with the diamondbacks he spent a few
years over in the kbo league now he's
back to the states
here's tati's junior has been getting
games started off with a bang here for
the padres we'll see what he does first
play to parents tonight in the air to
deep left field he started another game
with another lead off home run
bottom of the first inning takes it out
of the yard his sixth home run of the
year for fernando tatis jr
who does it again good way to start
every ball game
kid you are unbelievable this kid's like
a a playstation character
he's just pulled ahead of kilby ovaris
and chris dynorphia
in lead off home runs daddy machado
line to left field and that's gonna get
in quickly back towards the track on the
wall machado
headed for second base as peralta gets
it back in machado stands at second with
a one-on double
there was a two seamer down and they
dropped that head he was on that two
seamer down and out of the zone if
that's taken that's a ball he crushed
that
pitch here's nick ahmed batting out of
the nine spot for
the diamondbacks swinging a miss and
ahmed strikes out
four strikeouts for chris paddock one
down in the third inning
well it's not the curveball it's a
change up it's not the change if it's
the curveball here's the combio right
there
way out in front look at the hips
that'll bring up cole calhoun who walked
back in the first inning
hadigretti and on one and two a
curveball swung on and missed and he
strikes him out
five strikeouts for chris three with the
ball
and he does work a one two three third
inning garcia at second base to start
things here in the third
good start to the third inning for san
diego here is fernando tatis jr
this one is grounded back up the middle
into center field to base hit greg
garcia being stopped
at third as the throw comes back in
quickly from martay and it's first
and third with nobody out danny machado
now with one out here in the third
manning with a double
in the first inning but left at second
base and the first pitch of the event
to manny machado is grounded to third
escobar goes to second out back to first
ending any double play
so kelly gets a double play five four
three around the horn and machado hits
into his third
vp of the year time and go ahead runs on
base there on the fourth
pitch to vote lifted in the air that's
going to have the
length to get martay home to tie the
game myers makes a catch
starling tags he comes to the plate to
play
goes to second that's a sacrifice fly
for both this game is tied to one here
in the fourth
here's cole calhoun with two outs in the
fifth
this is the high fly ball in the center
field this is grisham
already calling coming on in no problemo
right alongside fam
and medium death left center the center
fielder makes the grab and that's all a
two-out single
well we go to the sixth sending back to
work goes the big right-hander chris
paddock 1-1
swings down the line and left and
there's his first
diamondback home run paddock gives up
the home run to starley martin
the dieback shoot on top two to one boy
did he smash that ball too
inside fastball and he just turned on it
full
count to stephen vogt with two outs here
in the top of the sixth inning
steven gets into one and hits it deep to
right field and that ball is in the
seats
steven vote his first as a diamondback
make it three to one d d-backs
two home runs in the inning off chris
paddock profile
batting for cronenworth tying run at the
plate two outs in the seventh
strike three got him looking and what
about him by chaffing tonight
he comes in he faces three strikes out
two
and he leaves the base runner we played
seven at petco
one out for pierce johnson he has had
ground ball issues
as he grounds this one into the shift
right side profar sliding down has it
off balance throw to first is in time
nicely done by jerks and profar just
into the game and
tested immediately makes the play two
away
just into the game kind of lost the
handle right there but has the
wherewithal to stay with it make that
submarine throw on to first base just in
time to get david
home run to lead it off in the first
inning single to center in the third
high drive deep left field for tatis not
one
but two home runs out of the yard for
tatis brings the padres within a run
seventh home run of the year for
fernando tatis junior
who will touch them all and hosmer comes
up
osmore hits a fly ball to right field
john jay at the track he's got it
out number two boy he just missed by the
way hossman reacted i thought he might
have got it
myers tonight oh for three he's punched
out twice
breaking ball hit the left and there's
peralta he's got it
and the diamondbacks gonna come from
behind wind tonight